explore
if you're not sure what to do with your
life if you're not sure what business
you want to run if you have a
uncertainty in your life
explore
don't put so much pressure on yourself
to find the right thing the perfect
thing right away because
that's not usually how things happen
you have to give yourself the chance to
explore
try things out
see what works see what you enjoy
if you don't like it quit go do
something else if you like something
keep going and see where it leads
this comes as a result of a question
from nick who's one of my youtube
viewers love you guys
wrote the long email now nick guys you
got to shorten up the emails i love that
you're kind of pouring your hearts out
but this takes time to read
anyway nick is 19 years old and is
unsure what to do next okay he's a
business major he loves technology he
loves business he loves the internet he
loves staying on top of tech trends and
he's unsure what to do next what do i do
next
nick don't put so much pressure on
yourself okay
just explore
so maybe that means going to get a job
at a tech company maybe that means
starting up some kind of business
website or tech resource yourself see
what's missing in the world
and try to make something or try to
learn something by working at another
business
and see if you enjoy it
if you're not sure what your passion is
try different things out
something will stick
and don't put so much pressure you have
to find the right thing right away a
while ago i took art classes okay it's
like i got to do something different i
want to i want to explore something new
so i said okay i'm going to do art
classes
and i kind of forced myself to go to
these art classes and
i wasn't very good
but i just wasn't enjoying it and for
some reason i kept going like i got to
get good at this
i was desperate to find something new
to explore
and forced it on this art class that
wasn't the right thing the art class was
not for me
i i left it i didn't sign up again
because i just wasn't having fun
and then earlier this year
i guess last year i took up snowboarding
i just went i went one day snowboarding
i'd never done it before and you know
what i loved it
i fell in love with snowboarding and i
started picking it up and started going
more frequently and getting better at it
so it's the same thing with finding a
business idea or finding your passion
don't force it on
i really want to go work at samsung so
i'm going to i'm going to go get this
job or i really want to be an
entrepreneur and then this has to be my
business it has to work out if you don't
have that vision you have to find it for
yourself
and you don't find it until you start to
explore
i'm reminded of steve jobs the founder
of apple he went to university and he
was he was bored like it wasn't for him
he didn't know what to do
and he's he dropped out of his classes
he dropped he officially dropped out of
university and instead
started dropping in on classes about
typography
fonts
and if you look at that from an outside
world you think steve what are you like
are you crazy what are you doing
you're dropping out of school
where you can go and get a real job out
of and get hired and make money and
survive
and instead of doing that
you're you're dropping in on classes
where you don't get a credit for to
learn about
writing and fonts are you crazy
and he didn't know what he was doing
either
okay at that time it wasn't all mapped
out for him he didn't know what he was
doing
but when he actually led to create apple
the thing that made apple different was
their fonts
apple had lots of different fonts where
all their competitors didn't
and that came because steve jobs had a
passion for fonts and sat in on those
classes
the point is you don't know how the dots
are going to connect you cannot plot
this thing you can't say this this is
this and i'm a success
you can't force yourself to do something
that you don't enjoy and love doing
if you try you will not be successful
so explore
find what excites you find what's your
what your passion is what you're excited
about
and then stick with that
and have the courage to leave something
that you don't like that's where most
people fall down they get stuck on a
career path that they realize more and
more that they hate but they're too
afraid to leave it to do something new
because they don't even know what to do
they don't know what that new thing is
so you stick on this mediocre life
you have to have the courage
to leave
the good the okay the mediocre
for something great even if you don't
know what that looks like yet
so start exploring
believe
for those of you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it always makes you want to do more and
let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath you have a question
leave it below i'll do a video response
for you thank you so much
and i'll see you soon